I was on Charlie Kirk's radio show
yesterday they it's video and radio it's
mostly a radio show but they simulcast
the video uh and we got into the
DeSantis uh Trump situation I just want
to say as I said up top Charlie and I
have been friends for years we've done
dozens and dozens of events together
usually with Turning Point USA uh
Charlie is firmly in the Trump Camp
Turning Point from my humble opinion is
basically a trump uh campaign arm right
like that that they that's what they in
effect are but Charlie was gracious
enough to have me on his show to say
what I think about DeSantis so he asked
me to make the case for governor
DeSantis here you go kind of make the
case especially to our conservative
audience and then secondly how do you
think his campaign is currently going
you in essence should be loving every
single thing that Ron DeSantis has done
I don't know one thing that Ron DeSantis
uh has not done that we would have
wanted him to do Florida is safe its
economy is absolutely booming we fund
the police here we're getting ESG out of
our institutions we've done that which
that's actually perhaps the biggest
issue that people don't talk about that
often because it's kind of In The Weeds
on how corporations are putting wokeness
on all of us I know you talk about it
but the average person doesn't they
certainly don't incorporate America he
has fought Disney he has fought the
endless racialization of our children by
getting rid of this AP African-American
studies course that was in essence going
to teach gender Theory we've gotten some
of these books that are sexualizing our
children out of schools he has done
literally everything that anyone
right-leaning could believe in or or
could possibly want to happen I would
say he's done one or two things that are
a little bit more like right-leaning
than I would want oh they're perfect for
me Dave I gotta say I love that stuff no
no absolutely but I would ask you what
is there anything that Ron DeSantis
you're you're at least a partner no he
he's he's America's greatest Governor
I've said that and I and by the way I've
said that repeatedly okay so it was good
to hear first off I want to credit
Charlie Charlie brought me on his show
to let me say what I believed him
obviously I went ahead and did it
Charlie said right there that uh
DeSantis has been America's greatest
Governor he later went on to say that I
think his exact quote was 100 when I
asked him if DeSantis was the best
Governor when it came to covid uh and
then we got into a little bit of my
criticisms around Trump I thought you
might find this one interesting
but here's what I would like to see out
of DeSantis we could talk after the
break Dave you know when we go to a
college campus you say hey if you
disagree go to the front of the line I
want to say I want to see somebody get
in the arena and say hey
I I'm willing to throw out the script
I'm willing to just take any question
I'm willing to kind of just fight it's
more kind of total and attitudinal
um Dave your reaction 20 seconds will
pick it up after the break
sure so look if in essence and we'll
pick it up after the break if in essence
your your point is oh I agree with
virtually all of the policies that
nobody has accomplished more than this
guy and done everything I want to do but
but there's a little bit of a marketing
issue here all right I'll go with you on
that and I think that can be dealt with
the base is very smart and they're
constantly looking in a way of who's
going to betray me next this is the
advice I gave to DeSantis privately and
publicly and right now the Rubicon has
been crossed where they think the Santa
is going to betray I'm not even saying
that's fair but I'm not saying it's
fairly I mean Trump trump has done far
more to betray the truth and and in a
certain way the the respect of the base
every time he lies about dissent right
so when he lies about covid and Florida
who was the best governor for Covenant
covet in the country DeSantis 100 but
who has more in who has done more work
and more praise for Paul Ryan is it
Rhonda santis or Donald Trump
for Paul Ryan I can't I can't speak
either way but at the same time we could
talk about getting after the break speak
either way I mean I can show you plenty
of videos of trump talking about how
much you love it I will agree with you
that in terms of some of the strategy of
the rollout they probably should have
been more aggressive I do see that
changing look DeSantis just went on uh
Russell Brand last week uh he just went
on CNN for the first time last week I
think he's doing Megan Kelly this week
if I'm not mistaken and she's been very
very critical of him uh Russell's a
lefty I mean he certainly uh is you know
no one that you would call a traditional
conservative by any stretch I would love
to see him go on The View sit directly
with those women and call out their
Endless Lies about Florida you know Anna
Navarro who lives in Miami who rails
against Florida every day he should sit
right next to her and call her out
um so if you want if your question is
really do you want to take some of the
the anger that the base has because of
the way Trump being treated at he's
being treated horribly and I completely
agree with it's righteous I agree I
agree there's probably some way to do
that but I would also say to some extent
if you just want to view this in the
political lens maybe this is why Trump
should stop lying about DeSantis every
which way and you know he is everything
he says about the scientist is a lie
everything he says I'll be honest it's
also a lie when DeSantis goes after
Trump and says he was profound she and
all that that's just not true but
without you in a word on the way out
we're out of time Dave Rubin thanks so
much